[Musique]
il y à une plantation de cannabis sur le
campus de l'université de technologie à
kingston capitale de la jamaïque
lasserre et cachés à la vue entourée
d'un grillage
seules les personnes autorisées peuvent
y accéder
le professeur à langenthal responsable
du centre de recherche sur le cannabis
échanges et du développement du secteur
médicinales de l'afld a coûté son
service a été crié il y a trois ans
après la dépénalisation
son collègue rachel berry professeur
assistant à l'université étudie et
répertorie les différentes variétés de
cannabis cultivés à la jamaïque
les plantes sont des hybrides 1dans d'un
cultivateur jamaïcain
chaque variété et identifiés par un nom
le responsable de la serre s'occupe
méticuleusement des plantes
ces ventilateurs maintiennent une
température constante sous la serre
il faut connaître le code de ce
conteneur pour y entrer les jeunes
plantes sont cultivées hi fi dans cette
noirceur y improviser selon la nouvelle
loi le cannabis doit pousser à l'abri
des regards dans des lieux sécurisés
ces chercheurs vont étudier les plantes
tout au long de leur croissance
il ne s'agit pas de donner aux gens de
l'herbe à fumer banque et cette défense
et notre université n'est pas intéressé
par ça
on s'est surtout penchée sur l'aspect
médicinales mais parfois c'est difficile
de faire partager cette idée aux
décideurs et même pas aux autorités
académiques qui doivent comme les
décisions concernant notre travail
je suis une scientifique dans le domaine
de la santé une pharmacienne de mitchie
je suis très excité par tout cela parce
que je vois le potentiel pour la
création de nouveaux médicaments dans le
monde de pâté c'est ça mon intérêt
dont les laboratoires de l'université
les scientifiques mesurent le niveau des
cannabinoïdes dans chaque plante
les échantillons sont séché et moulu
avant d'être analysée par cette machine
un coin 5 en deux elle utilise de la
lumière à pau détecter le thc
tétrahydrocannabinol est le cbd qu'un
habit diol le cbd soulage les symptômes
associés aux pathologies comme le
concert des diabètes et la sclérose en
plaques
le thc possède des qualités médicinales
mais modifie le fonctionnement psychique
cette plante un niveau élevé de thc vais
le voir ici
mais vers la moins de 2% de cbd s'est
très elle peut être utilisée pour
soigner l'épilepsie à calmer les
convolution il peut réduire la douleur
mais le problème c'est qu'il y ait un
niveau élevé de thc
donc il y aura une perturbation des
fonctionnements mentaux les hybrides
sont forts en thc
ce qui est intéressant pour la
consommation récréative de cbd et
surtout présentes dont les noni bride
ce sont ces variétés qui sont recherchés
par les scientifiques de l'université de
technologie pour poursuivre le travail
sur le cannabis médicinal
on a des variétés forte en scène était
ici mais c'est la minorité pour le multi
vendeurs qui veulent intégrer le secteur
de zinal cela peut s'avérer
problématique
il ya beaucoup de semences mazel sont
majoritairement forte en hd
[Musique]
ce docteur lots à 80 ans il est
spécialiste en chimie médicinale depuis
50 ans il étudie le cannabis il a
commencé à l'université de west indies
dans les années 60 en bravant toutes les
interdictions
nous avons commencé à étudier comment le
cannabis pourrait être valorisée sur le
plan initial nouveau traiter certaines
maladies
est ce aussi parce que la plante a
toujours été à médicaments traditionnels
[Musique]
les grands-mères donnait du thé de ganja
aux enfants si on souffrait d'une
entorse on se frottait avec une huile de
cannabis les mieux de son bureau sont
couverts de brevets américains pour
protéger les produits à base de cannabis
qu'il a développé au fil des années son
travail a été reconnue partout dans le
monde
il a publié des livres pour aider les
professionnels de la santé à comprendre
les bienfaits de la plante
dr lô a développé une gamme de goûter de
pommade à base de cannabis pour soigner
le glaucome calmer les douleurs
promouvoir le sommet est soulagé les
inflammations
le docteur est catégorique aucune plante
ne propose aux tombes de remède pour des
maladies aussi diverses on dit que la
jamaïque a produit le meilleur cannabis
ou ganja ça c'est pour les fumeurs il ya
le côté bestial
nous sommes seulement concerné par
l'aspect médicinales nous fabriquons nos
propres produits laboratoire a même
trouvé un produit un isolat de cannabis
qui soigne la leucémie qui il a déjà
obtenu la désignation de médicament
orphelin aux états unis forme
[Musique]
dr noël à bord s'est produit dans ce
laboratoire flambant neuf situé sur le
campus de l'université des west indies
la construction des installations a
coûté 750 mille dollars
c'est la deuxième faculté de la jamaïque
à travailler sur le développement du
cannabis médicinal et thérapeutiques
d'octo n'embauchent que des jeunes
scientifiques dans son laboratoire
le produit brut est stocké dans une
pièce hautement sécurisé une empreinte
de pouce d'une poignée de personnes
permet d'ouvrir la porte dont le
réfrigérateur une nuit d cannabis et
garder au frais c'est l'une des bases
des produits fabriqués dans ce
laboratoire on réceptionne autres
cannabis dans une solution d'alcool ou
d'éthanol on l'amène dans le laboratoire
pour l'extraction
on en rêve l'alcool et l'éthanol de la
plante et ça devient cette substance
gélatineuse et collante notre extrait de
cannabis s'est uni concentration de thc
et ses bd de tous les autres
cannabinoïdes présent dans la plante des
sacs de ganja séchées sont empilés sur
les étagères les feuilles sont les
ingrédients essentiels pour plusieurs
produits
grâce à la nouvelle législation les
techniciens travaillent en toute
légalité sur l'élaboration de nouveaux
produits
aujourd'hui c'est une crème chorale à
base de chanvre qui est en phase de
finition bonne viscosité et 3,7 à fait
pas trop pépère c'est un trophée
il faut que je vais la bonne consistance
c'est notre taille
aujourd'hui une fois très
cette pharmacie est l'une des rares
autorisés à vendre les produits de
doctorat la jamaïque dégoûté sabline
goual et des pommades tout homologués
par le ministère de la santé sont
stockés derrière le comptoir pour
acheter les gouttes
il faut une ordonnance et la vie du
pharmacien à fin mai c'est cela qui sait
c'est le pharmacien qui doit vendre ses
produits pas être en vente libre
nous devons montrer aux patients comment
les utiliser however as je n'ai jamais
fait de publicité sauf ils se vendent
tout seuls ils vont pas être les gens
les achètent
[Musique]
à la jamaïque les canalise pas senti de
la pharmacologie traditionnel des puits
son temps mais cela fait seulement trois
ans que les médecins traitants du pays
ont le droit de conseiller le gadjo au
patient ou soigner diverses pathologies
le docteur neuf baleines et consultons
anesthésiste
en 2001 il a ouvert une clinique pour
soigner les patients hayon des douleurs
chroniques
janet code ont fait partie victime d'un
accident de circulation qui a écrasé son
assia tic
jared cohen a subi plusieurs
interventions chirurgicales rien à
soulager la douleur permanente avec
lequel elle vit depuis quinze ans le
docteur baleine lui a prescrit de la
morphine des opioïdes des infiltrations
de cortisone et d'autres drogues fork
son résultat positif
j'étais fatigué france des opioïdes
si ce n'était pas les audioguides
c'était les anti inflammatoires non
salées logica beaucoup de ces
médicaments
je prends un nouveau aujourd'hui et
demain je ne le tolère plus et ça fait
des dégâts mon estomac
j'ai tout arrêté
un matin j'ai tout jeté dans les
toilettes je n'en pouvais plus janet
golden a mené ses propres recherches sur
le cannabis le docte baleine est
autorisée par le ministère de la santé à
le prescrire janet gordon qui a
l'autorisation de cultiver son herbe
chez elle fabrique elle même sont
l'huile qu'elle applique sur les pentes
y douloureuse de son corps un simple
soin qui a changé sa vie alors mes pieds
je souffre de douleurs névralgique et il
ya quelque chose dans le cannabis et qui
soulage les douleurs névralgique et ça
marche et si ça continue danger je vais
continuer à l'utiliser pas dire que
c'est la panacée on ne peut pas croire à
des formules magiques et dire que c'est
la seule chose qui marche comme un
élément dans un programme pour contrôler
les douleurs je pense que ça fera un
bien faible
gloria palomino à 81 ans femme
d'affaires qui dirige deux restaurants
renommés à kingston madame palomino a
été récompensé par le gouvernement pour
ses oeuvres caritatives
il y a 20 ans on lui a diagnostiqué un
lupus et j'ai décidé quand j'ai eu le
diagnostic
je n'allais jamais prendre les
médicaments dits traditionnels à cause
d'effets secondaires
j'ai décidé que je ne prendrais rien les
douleurs des articulations un soutien
avec le lupus devenait de plus en plus
importante
c'est doit commencer à être déformés par
la maladie depuis l'introduction de la
nouvelle législation
un médecin lui a prescrit des jets lieu
de chanvre gloria palomino constate une
nette amélioration
jean pinet tous les jours dès maintenant
j'en prends qu'il dit parce que la
douleur commence à partie et ça dans un
court laps de temps
je suis surpris au début le doigt était
plié comme ça impossible de le déplier
et non et si ça devient tout droit et
que je n'ai plus de douleurs
m
[Musique]
on se rendra à la première est dispensée
à de gandja à la jamaïque
il faut prendre la route vers la vie de
ocho rios située sur la côte nord de
l'île qu'à un dispensaire a ouvert ses
portes au mans ce 2018
les dispensaires avec ses propres terres
de culture hautement sécurisé représente
un investissement d'un million de
dollars le dispensaire est un lieu
d'achat et de consommation ou des
personnes avec ou sans ordonnance ou
comtois on propose plusieurs variétés de
cannabis toutes sortes d'accessoires
sont disponibles pour les clients
ces touristes américaines ont été amenés
par un chauffeur de taxi
une fois le produit acheté l'employé et
madame à le consommer ce vieux monsieur
accompagné de son fils est venu voir
barham vaswani fondateur de cette
entreprise
le vieil homme souffre de glaucome les
médecins qui prescrivent à le cannabis
pour besoin médicinales ne sont pas
présents ce jour là ils seront obligés
de revenir ou consultez ailleurs il a
fait des recherches
essayez des produits du marché noir pour
trôner sur le cob
maintenant il veut de l'authentic mes
opérations dispensées à sont surveillés
de près par les autorités jamaïcaines
c'est le premier lieu dont le pays où la
vente et la consommation récréative est
permise et cela uniquement dans des
zones fermées
free est aussi réglementée que les
casinos la sécurité les caméras les
registre informatisé et manuscrits à la
faute à deux pas du dispensaire la
compagnie cultive 25 variétés dé
cannabis sur une superficie de deux
hectares et demi dont la nuance jury les
plantes sont cultivées dont dépôt elles
seront transférées sous serre chaque
plante à des taux différentes de thc et
de cbd
d'espoir les voici notre variété de cbd
elle contient 10% de cette idée est
moins d'un pour cent des th
tout cela est totalement bidon lasserre
et sécurisé avec un digicode les
autorités imposent un carrier de change
important aux cultivateurs des centaines
de plants poussent dans des conditions
contrôlées elles sont destinées à la
vente dans les dispensaires ou aux
clients autorisé par le gouvernement
pour mener des recherches et la
transformation au bal ram vaswani qui a
suivi une formation aux états unis dont
le conditionnement du cannabis la
jamaïque un vrai avantage ceux d'autres
pays en la matière des pays comme le
canada n'ont pas le bec de la vie qui
fait avec cette plante
partout l aja mali via ce mode de vie
cette énergie ainsi d'accepter cela nous
faire avancer parce que ça fait partie
de notre culture
les plantes sont re coté et sécher dans
une température contrôler chaque variété
est identifié par le bas
le conditionnement du cannabis est fait
à la main
les bourgeons sont séparés des branches
les feuilles séchées son cahier afin de
laisser les têtes prêtes à la
consommation
au total la compagnie embauche que des
40 personnes dont les différentes étapes
de ces opérations il ya des machines
pour ça et je suis pas favorable je
préfère embaucher des gens au lieu
d'avoir une machine qui fait la dgac
ça donne une touche personnelle quand
ses compères la note
[Musique]
l'industrie des cannabis a été placé
sous la responsabilité du ministère de
l'industrie du commerce de l'agriculture
et de la pêche au sein du ministère
là c est là et l'autorité qui délivre
les licences pour la culture le
transport la transformation la recherche
et la vente de cannabis
elle est dirigée par un sens lightbourne
avocate âgée de 41 ans elle travaille
avec 15 personnes pour crier et faire
respecter les règles de fonctionnement
de ce nouveau secteur
ces règlements sont criés au fur et à
mesure quand il n'existe aucun précédent
dans la caraïbe anglophone devait
jeunesse
la perspective c'est de créer une
autorité pour la promotion d'une
industrie qui profite à tous il
industrie qui changera le pays et la
mauvaise réputation du gang jardin on
commence chez nous un petit pays grande
exportés à l'étranger
le développement de l'industrie du
cannabis est freinée par le secteur
bancaire les banques de la jamaïque
refuse d'encaisser des revenus de tous
ceux qui travaillent dans la cannabis et
dont la fabrication de produits dérivés
les bancs de la jamaïque travaille avec
des partenaires américains qui sont
contraints par la loi fédérale des états
unis
a refusé toute transaction liés au
commerce du cannabis aux fans ce fait
libres tout l'argent qui quitte la
jamaïque transitent par des 100
correspondants c'est une entreprise est
conservée par la marie konin qui est
classique comme drogues illicites par
les lois fédérales et aux états unis
sa mère la relation entre la banque et
de résistants et la banque et la
jamaïque
on a déjà eu les entreprises qui avaient
des comptes bancaires et leur langue et
leur ont demandé de clôture quelqu'un
doit inventer un système en harmonie
avec les lois pour que ces monstres et
puissent travailler avec les ventes sont
sans occupation prioritairement la
question de la sécurité
on ne veut pas que quelqu'un se promène
avec les gestes de billet en quarts
l'inévitable de ce produit et l'ancien
ministre de la justice en 2015
il a rédigé la nouvelle législation sur
les cannabis votée à l'unanimité par
l'assemblée
[Applaudissements]
son parti n'est plus au pouvoir
aujourd'hui et lé député dans la
circonscription de saint-andré c'est là
que se trouve la communauté de
trenchtown ou bob marley a vécu et écrit
plusieurs albums
c'est un lieu de pèlerinage pour ses
fans
la nouvelle loi a changé la vie des
habitants de ce quartier d'el hadary and
was a sauf quand l'ancien mois et est
une source permanente roi la police et
des jeunes hommes la sûreté dans les
communautés défavorisées comme celle ci
nous nous trouvons c'est une réforme
importante du point de vue des droits
civiques
je suis heureux que nos pulls à côté
assez rapidement pour les âges personnel
nous avons voir d'arrestation et de
détention provisoire mais c'est que le
pouvoir de poursuite et le casier
judiciaire nous avons purgé des anciens
casier judiciaire des condamnations pour
possession de matinée
la consommation de cannabis reste
interdite aux mineurs et dans des lieux
publics la réforme respecte tous les
traités internationaux concernant le
cannabis dont la jamaïque est signataire
le cannabis est une source potentielle
de développement économique
je suis déçu que le gouvernement n'ait
pas vraiment février nous de trouver un
moyen de faciliter l'accès des petits
planteurs et de les aider à intégrer
deux circuits officiels je pense que des
exigences réglementaires sont tout le
monde pour des petits planteurs et qu'il
faut développer une politique dynamique
pour accompagner leur participation
[Musique]
dans le village de pêcheurs situé à 30
km de kingston ne peut pas seul en cause
il est accueilli par canon diana et
raspail à elle est venue visiter ce lieu
qui depuis la réforme bénéficie d'un
statut particulier la communauté rast
feria est désormais autorisé à cultiver
le cannabis et le consommer dans des
endroits appelé les sanctuaires
aujourd'hui les avait reconnus par le
gouvernement comme la plante sacrée des
rastafari utilisés dans des cérémonies
religieuses de la communauté compte
reconnaît nos membres
on est déclarée auprès du ministère de
la justice
familier avec les noms de nos mains la
fréquence d'une réunion une fois par
mois et d'autres informations le
changement de loi de nos rasta
l'autorisation légale d'utiliser la
marijuana on ne peut pas être poursuivi
pour la consommation dans les trois
mails pour son utilisation religieuse
est un droit religieux maintenant pour
les rastas la communauté rastafarienne a
longtemps été poursuivi et parfois
persécuté pour son utilisation d'herbe
aujourd'hui les sanctuaires comme
celui-ci cultive les différents types de
ganja consommée par les membres de
groupes les rastafarienne pratiquer la
culture biologique et des produits
alimentaires sont cultivés à côté des
plants de cannabis
l'étude qu'il advienne quest nos membres
nous ont blindé de la plante et donc il
nous faut la voir tout le temps des
soins après leur latin
cette variété avec un air de sapins de
noël s'appelle lines brad elf ou son
planeur c'est l'une des espèces
endémiques à la jamaïque
elle est reconnue pour sa forte teneur
en cbd voici notre lance bref oui c'est
notre spécialité ici sur ce texte soit
un sur six est original variétés
cultivées à la jamaïque depuis un bon
moment il était dit que les ouvriers
indiens engagés sous contrat longtemps
c'est avec l'allemagne
les restos farine transforme le leinster
dans l'huile essentielle
plusieurs membres du sanctuaire ne fume
pas ils préfèrent consommer le cannabis
sous forme liquide
[Musique]
de nombreux étrangers profitent de la
réforme pour investir à la jamaïque
ils veulent tous mettent la main sur les
variétés endémique
le professeur réserves ont péché que ces
variétés soit un brevet tep an de pays
tiers
elle veut aider les américains à
protéger leur patrimoine et leur savoir
faire et qui ne pensons commencer le
processus
d'abord protéger les connaissances et
leur savoir faire
il faut le faire rapidement un truc
parce que beaucoup de ces étrangers ne
connaissent pas grand chose malgré leurs
déclarations contraires réalité ils
viennent d'apprendre d'eux nous a
parfois d'une manière qui nous plaisent
à des situations défavorables et nous
connaissance de vienne le label de leurs
produits les gens viennent pour cela il
veut le label et voir in jamaïca la
réforme des lois sur le cannabis a
changé la vie de beaucoup de jamaïquains
des pistes de développement économiques
se sont ouvertes dans les domaines de la
recherche la culture et la bande des
opportunités qui vont se multiplier
qu'on les institutions financières
investiront le secteur le cannabis
longtemps diabolisés sont prises en
compte de ces qualités médicinales
entame sa réhabilitation à la jamaïque
[Musique]